[Music]
young person's services to sport or
community sponsored by Lamar's amber
holiday amber is a true role model to
her peers and younger students she
actually didn't always enjoy PE she'd do
it happy enough but it wasn't an
inspiration to her then she threw
herself into the girls active unit of
work and discovered a love for a variety
of activities her progress at South
dartmoor also led to her doing some work
as an ambassador for active Devon's
Devon girls can initiative a task is to
inspire others to be physically active
she's certainly doing this at school but
she also posed to active Devon's
Instagram page to show what she's doing
in the hope to encourage others amber
also did a takeover of the active girls
active national Instagram page inspiring
people nationwide and now he's thinking
to becoming a PE teacher so she can
inspire others
Kelvin Hickman Kelvin has been training
a martial art to the past five years and
regularly assists in the little Pumas
lessons despite his age and his own
training Kelvin is amazing with the
younger children demonstrating within
the class as well as also taking smaller
groups and teaching them on a personal
level
Kelvin volunteers his time for free and
expects nothing in return because of his
knowledge and patience within the class
the little Pumas aged four to seven
continues to grow and flourish due to
his caring personality he's a pleasure
to have in the class and his passion for
martial arts will continue to be passed
on through the generations to come
Libby Hill an integral part of the team
breach Titans netball Club
Libby Hill has been volunteering weekly
at under 11 and under 12 sessions as
well as working towards her coaching and
umpiring Awards
nothing is ever too much for Libby and
she's completed over 200 hours
volunteering and has brought out
confidence in so many new starters to
the club she's a much-loved member of
the coaching team Libby completed her
into officiating course learning how she
can umpire and officiate the game and
now volunteers in the senior team Britta
League at just 14 years old she instills
great passion and confidence into all
titans members and they can't thank her
enough for all the work she puts in she
always has a smile and gives the girls
lots of support and encouragement
[Music]
you